foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Austin Texas it's great to be
here in the heart of live music and the
capital of Texas as well
uh thank you uh thank you for
introducing the guest Nick sapaglia
usually that's my job but uh you know
you did that anyways thanks thanks you
[ __ ]
doesn't that guy look like the kid from
hereditary
um no that's not okay that's his joke to
do uh but my name is Hans Kim I am
pushed up here getting ready to judge
dates uh this is uh the perch of Destiny
I'm looking down upon you uh and we're
gonna have a date for like 90 seconds
we're gonna pull someone up interview
them then uh sit them down and then pull
up the other person and they're gonna
come up and go on a date with that
person and then after 90 seconds we're
gonna just interview them slash roast
them
Marissa Leslie uh but thank you for
coming hopefully uh you guys won't be a
mid bite if your name gets called
um you can just wipe your hands down
unless you like to keep your hands
greased just in case you need to give a
quick little HJ under the table
a little Burger filled HJ
but uh it should be a fun show you know
it's a small little holiday show Let's
uh get cozy and you know pass around
gifts
such as smiles and just handshakes and
just get to know each other
okay no one did it
but enough uh foreplay let's get to the
meat of action we gotta guess here that
uh Nick Rush actually spoiled and ruined
uh but this comedian is a very funny
comedian he has this one joke where he's
like hey I'm a huge old gay person and
I'm stupid
very funny guy very smart very straight
give it up for Nixa Paglia human male
hello Nick
hello hello I like how you added that
stupid tag to my joke yeah
you know me always tagging it up I'm a
consonant professional love that joke
that you put up online about
[Music]
something yeah I joke about some things
some things we got two
we got three males and two females
someone but that's a tradition
uh let's get a woman up here let's just
see what she's all about
the woman is Fiona from Shrek
here she is
fresh from the bathroom
Fiona
come on up the stairs are right around
there yeah through the door
she is wearing a tracksuit so she could
bound up on stage
hello
oh
make yourself at home
we're going with a very green team today
uh what what inspired the green pick up
the mic and just say what you're feeling
green is a great color
Good Vibes money grass
all I know is money and grass
yeah
the audience is loving it Fiona
what are what are you looking for in a
beautiful partner
someone who is patient okay why are you
gonna do some crazy [ __ ] are you very
aggravating to be around yes
you're wearing green again
I have no patience for green this isn't
style you really are just that obnoxious
to our all green I get it
well I'm loving it you know you look
like
uh a Teletubby uh I don't know who wears
green
Power Ranger you look like he could be
working the field crew at Fenway Park
you look like Gumby
[Music]
you really like the first female NFL
head coach
bear I'm rusted
please sign up we'll rust YouTube
uh and now oh some woman signed up or
did I miscount I mean I don't know you
are ancient so you should have counted
properly the first time we do nothing
proper the first time have you seen our
bridges in China yeah
we got a man named Sean Wheeling
Wheeling
going on a date for 90.
two seconds 92. I'm giving him an extra
two seconds okay just because he's
wearing blue blue and green let's see
who wins
starting now 92 seconds of dating action
yeah just date her just date her up
date the [ __ ] out of her dude
I'll grab it
it's maybe because
what do you like to do for fun
oh
but
good efforts
yeah
what do you do for work
I work at a hospital
with my and babies
it's cool what do you do for work
Pokemon
professional poker yeah
excuse me
oh look
yeah
like a scratch off
these things yep
um I'm from Hawaii I grew up there and
then I've lived in Texas for about five
years now which do you like
um there's pros and cons to both but I
would say I like Texas more
better academic setting and
um
just more and time
give it up for the reality-based Fiona
yeah
and Wheeling Mr Wheeling I would say put
the mic closer to your mouth but I don't
think that'll help
well said
what uh what brings you out tonight what
are you looking for in a beautiful date
[Music]
you're married all right nice oh gosh
what a tease
[Music]
put it in here today Fiona I'm sorry
just coming out showing Fiona what she
can't have you know
really leading her on breaking hearts
out here what do you think about uh
being married how did you meet your wife
High School
30 years ago
you just got together three years ago oh
that was a long long unrequinted love
and then became recorded
four total hell yeah
you guys congratulations
you guys have uh twins that are dating
each other too yeah yeah
oh my God you guys are gonna create
brothers that have different parents
I don't know what's going on hopefully
you guys are taking 23andMe
yeah
you got two twins
[Music]
they did it three times and got four
kids cool all right
I got you dude I got you man
wow sex three times yeah dude it's
pretty good for nerds like us
pretty good so uh that's cool you got uh
three four kids you know that's that's
pretty good return on investment for a
poker player
exactly what do you like about poker
the money hell yeah dude
you like money Fiona likes money this I
don't know we gotta think we got some
Sparks you know
yeah what uh why did you wear blue
tonight
it's a goof the Cubs just give you that
that's what I got from
the cook oh wow
you're a homeboy
nice is he black he's black
that's why he's our own boy
yeah Ronnie Ronnie that's our homeboy
Jack
the third base coach wow
not the most athletic position but still
an honor to be nominated
oh yeah you have to Play It Again
Fiona do you like baseball
you just dressed like one
a baseball field
awesome
what uh what sports are you into
swimming all of high school and middle
school is that how you got out of Hawaii
swim here but I guess I guess I could
have swam yeah yeah women can do
anything men can do did you have any
aspirations for like going pro but then
got discouraged because all the men
started joining and beating the [ __ ] out
of all of you
are you a man
yeah
yeah
swimming and girls
kind of my life is swimming in with
girls
and around them uh uh it's Wheeling
do you ever see any women in poker
and uh do you have to wear a wig to play
with them or no
[Music]
Um
poker is very Progressive they don't
separate based on gender you know
that's right yeah and money
well that's good what's your poker face
like I just imagined when you said poker
it was online you know
the
wow you gotta freak people out when you
got like a good hand you're like
[Music]
yeah
it just works you gotta Poker Face you
got poker voice
got the whole package
poker poker face poker voice palsy body
exactly that's right poke your
girlfriend three times get four kids
so uh that's cool do you think that uh
women are better Liars than men
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
we don't yeah we like like
yeah thank you we Lie For the Love of
the Game they're doing it all
robotically
Fiona what was the worst lie you ever
told
yeah you like that don't you
it came right to Red instantly she's
like [ __ ]
um
tell me later I want to hear it
[Laughter]
do you have a wife as well does everyone
have a wife here I do not have a
okay you just look like a sister wife
as Mormonism reached Hawaii yet
um
there are some Mormon people in Hawaii
but I'd say there's more Mormon people
in Arizona and Utah yeah we know that we
were asking about Hawaii no not really
in Hawaii
we make them here
they're a domestic products the
factories are all in Utah
anyways so that's cool you uh you have a
secret that you don't want to share to
all of us here
we don't know which one it is so you can
pick another one of your terrible
secrets
I cheated on my high school trigonometry
exam by putting my notes inside of the
calculator slip-on thing and typed it in
0.3 font so if you're ever needing to if
you can read that small
that's a good trick
I totally thought you're gonna say
trigonometry professor
I was so excited this is going to go
somewhere else but then you just showed
everyone you're a [ __ ] nerd
you didn't even get to come at the end
of this cheating
that's cool you uh wrote it down or you
printed it out you cheated
what a cheater
that's cool yeah we actually uh have a
direct line to your high school right
now we're gonna get your diploma
rescinded you're gonna have to go
through med school all over again
sophiano what do you do for a living
[Music]
do they know that you're there
yeah ask them what their babies names
are and then when it's really weird I
asked them how they came up with that
name and then it's less weird because
they have a backstory what's the
weirdest name
everyone was thinking probably there
were these twins renaya and Renee that's
what you guys named your twins Jesus
to it all day and twiddle down
and that was a weird Choice why did they
say they did that were they game with
their owns fans
but the older older one was going to be
renaya and the next one was going to be
Renea so I
guess it's just a name she liked but
there's a hyphen before the
first two letters
damn that's some white [ __ ] how
white were these people
they weren't white
uh were they black
how do you know
you're from Florida
oh hell yeah
are you from Florida dude what do you
like about uh Texas
um
please
um
I don't know like
the yeah because recovery shares really
depends
that makes a lot of sense I think uh I
was gonna ask does everyone in Florida
talk like this yeah
it's just that that's the standard
Florida accent
yeah
I mean
we're holding the conversation pretty
well I guess yeah
so uh What uh what what how did dates
usually go do you uh before you met your
wife like where were you prowling
um like I did pretty good for a while
which is like
if you're successful
yeah women are [ __ ] if you have money
they'll come to you we all know that
like yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
you're going on a date with a married
man is this the first married man you've
been on a date with
cheating on your trigonometry tests LED
you to a life of crime
how did you uh go on a date with this
other married man
my wife just gave birth you want to go
get a drink
I just knocked your wife out we have
three hours
by the way your children's names are
Reina and renera
you're gonna have to redo the
relationship already make kids I don't
know anyways so that's cool you uh
you're like a doula or like a midwife or
no I do registration so I check in the
moms and babies and make sure they're
all their profiles are all set up and
damn they got profiles already so you
give every per every baby you see their
barcode for Life basically you set them
up with a Tinder account
like this Baby's gonna be [ __ ] or a
grinder depending
but that's cool
um what do you what have you learned
about
children and mothers um
yeah it's basic it's just like Marie
[Laughter]
in the crowd
a standby oh Marie
oh that's the sound of uh you guys
having a [ __ ] now
[Laughter]
he's just joking are you really in an
open relationship
[Music]
school
yeah yeah what is the freakiest thing
that you guys have done
oh yes the translate bring the
translator up on this one
let's get all the details
wow
she's like coked out but cool right
for a while and then she's like you know
what let's start a business let's open a
bar
yeah yeah
nice a video to go away cool yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah I like that yeah see I
know what's the longest relationship
you've been in
one year of
hot midwifing action
what how did you meet this one-year
Wonder
hell yeah
in Hawaii or no in Texas
nice a mainlander
what do people uh say when they find out
you're from Hawaii
they go oh my gosh that's so cool and
then I say yeah it's okay
for someone born in Hawaii you're just
as boring as the rest of us yeah
you got the tan of someone who was born
in Wisconsin you know
to use a lot of sunblock I'm sure
whoa a super white pure blood
then Kanye would like a word with you
well give it up for this lovely couple
it's Fiona and Wheeling give it up for
them thank you guys thank you so much
for coming out
thank you
now back to the brown of the stage Fair
on the stage
we got another couple coming up let's
interview this strange lady named
Melissa rickelman
I think that's how it says
we know her middle name oh yeah Marie
[Applause]
try not to say her last name too many
times
someone might steal her social security
information
this is being broadcast to YouTube as we
speak FYI
and a chattahoo in the building
that's very good
what a coward barkeep could I have a
Jameson and ginger ale please
any women want to sign up
we need more vaginas
this is a yeah women are precious
commodity they gotta preserve them yeah
that's what society says yeah yeah it's
very patriarchal mindset
anyways Alyssa what is what brings you
out tonight
that's tomorrow that's another show
okay well stop advertising for that show
that show's already doing fine
well that's cool uh What uh how did you
get into kill Tony
very stressful job
just start watching a lot of Comedy to
not think about it
nice
what is your job I'm a therapist that's
good
I'm glad you're not out there assigning
people middle names with a middle name
like Marie yeah it's pretty boring
my kids and her mom's moms were very
basic
nice
oh Nick's gonna get his drink
it's all about that drink
um that's cool uh so are you here with
your boyfriend
okay well thanks
keeping your options open
what uh what what did What attracted to
you to your boyfriend
wow that's what he calls his dick
it did actually a little bit a little
bit
wow so that works
that was fun yeah I've never done that
move myself you should it worked just
whacking ladies
what uh where did he hit you with a pool
noodle
right in the kisser he's so spontaneous
he just out of nowhere came up and
assaulted me
yeah no [ __ ]
and are you in danger right now blink
twice
sir are you in danger right now
so does the
at her job was it in a pool no
it was outside
he just assaulted you you did he yeah
were you guys like shopping together or
were you strangers we were getting
pedicures
yeah
nice why did he have a wet noodle like
in a pedicure place
owned it they're just out of the friend
zone at the time actually oh you
graduated he made it out
goodness all you need is a giant pool
noodle of a deck it's holiday
basically you friend zoned him until he
wore like gray sweatpants around you're
like holy [ __ ] it's all right no more
not not too far off
shallow stitches
and now you are from Florida right
that's how they communicate over there
it is
Naples
yeah we got Shadow coming up yeah I love
that that's amazing
signed up just in time
I got not that many women left
we might have to we're gonna have two
dudes go on a date that's gonna be great
I'd have to ration these women out
how you doing I'm good nice nice to meet
you
so you came out for kill Tony huh I did
well that's awesome but uh you know lose
him before you get back or you gotta
take him with you depends on how the day
goes extra baggage
I mean I already paid for it oh you paid
for it yeah oh there's a good chance
here so
I'm just kidding
so we got 90 seconds right so um where
are you from Naples Naples you did say
that earlier you're a good listener I am
not yeah sarcasm yeah so yeah he'll
listen to you I'll just do the rest okay
we're on our date yeah exactly I I like
this already
so I like the I like the beanie it's
very nice that you're is it knit or did
you buy it I bought it oh it looks nice
it looks again yeah it looks handy but
not handy I'm not a very good girly girl
oh cool
that's good to know
where are you from I recently moved here
from Arizona okay yeah but I've Been
Everywhere why
my parents moved around a lot I only got
to stay like two two years into play so
I never made friends military no just
[ __ ] okay same thing yeah
they didn't kill anybody yeah I mean I
mean they're just [ __ ] for the [ __ ]
of it let's go say
I do get that Vibe a lot I do I do hear
that I can tell uh but I'm more like not
a serial killer but more like I saw you
out there but you didn't see me you know
I'm just around just a creeper yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
a good man that likes to see you from a
distance
yeah
we always know you're there right just
like just so you know yeah we see you
and time give it up for a shadow
digging himself into a hole that's
deeper than the friend zone hole
to the stalker hole
it's a good place to stalk though it is
you can always see your eyes
and uh Alyssa how did you uh think that
date went
you like a lot of First Dates
over eager little yeah exactly what I
was gonna say a little over eager okay
you did good thank you
competitions in the room I had to do I
had to be a little over a year there you
go he's looking right at me right now
it's a little intimidating we don't have
as much access to women as you do in
Florida we gotta get it all out at once
yeah Naples from Florida okay yes
again not not a great listener Italian
or something we set it over microphones
I'm just being funny Naples do you know
where Naples is it's around the areola
nice this guy's got a one-track mind
he's already working his way thinking
about different ways to stimulate you
[Laughter]
um
what's your what's your move do you like
the areola
uh uh I'm a more uh between the size
type of guy you know and what do you
like that she does between your thighs
no I'll be between her yeah yeah now
we're just getting a little bit into it
but uh
I I'm more of a an oral guy you're a
giver I'm a giver yeah that's what they
all say I'm beginning
that's what guys a small dicks say
what uh what have you noticed about
people that say they're uh givers
uh they're generally
small [ __ ]
me ah see I got big dick energy just not
didn't do that either
you got small dick energy I'm confident
about it and a big dick
well that's that's fine you know you can
have whatever size dick you want thank
you judging here I appreciate that she
has no dick that's how confident she is
yeah I haven't seen it
oh that's uh she's sitting more
cross-legged I mean that's a tricky move
you're trying to uh see her vagina by
saying she has a dick
yeah
so our wheel at least 37 people on
YouTube right now
um Nick what do you think about this uh
couple he's obviously you know Well Chad
you came dressed to impress you know you
look like Brad Pitt from fight club
sandwich thank you I appreciate that
I like the nose ring it's very uh Craft
on YouTube Shadow yeah for us I guess
yeah
this is my time okay I'm just kidding I
thought it was new I was just maybe look
like
you came swinging right out of the gate
like you were really determined to cut
her boyfriend which was like I thought
that was impressive you know I get good
form but you just you know you lacked in
the uh performance aspect of it we have
it before I can show her boyfriend what
I can perform I bet you would show her
boyfriend
it looks like he can handle it what
would you do with Alyssa's boyfriend was
I think we go play pool and then uh
maybe watch a UFC fight uh no you put
some balls in Holes
okay he's not cool at all he didn't like
he didn't like watching do you like UFC
oh okay there we go
you like playing pool
you prefer I prefer hockey just that's
not a real fight man there's always
somebody breaking it up
hey it's Nick Roche hey Nick coming in
from behind trying to cuck everyone's
girlfriend Nick exchanges these
microphones three times a show but I've
never seen him thank you Chad it's the
segment no like
well testing testing oh hey man give it
up for Nick Roach
producer
sound guy
so Alyssa what uh what do you what do
you think about uh dating in Austin so
far what do you have to say about
Florida versus Texas guys
uh
I mean he's neither of those but
um so far Arizona's okay not bad there
you go not bad what do you think that
you would do here how long have you like
have you seen anything fun that you
might want to take Chad to
um she does pay I do I do I got that I
got that green
[Laughter]
I got weed she's got that therapist
money that's true a lot of people have a
lot of problems yeah are you able to
smoke weed with you especially in
Florida I can yeah okay cool yeah yeah
oh yeah absolutely it's it's job
security for sure
anyone uh ever come in high on meth or
something am I actually when I worked in
Texas I used to work with like drug
addicts and psychotic people what's the
worst thing someone's ever told you they
did
can't violate HIPAA or whatnot but just
don't say any names just say the action
like I mean
I've well one of the at one point I
spent an hour trying to convince
somebody who thinks he's a vampire to
get a dead possum out of his doorway
that seems like an easy thing to do you
would you would think so
how did it go I
um
not well
[Music]
what did what did what did he tell you
that he did to that dead possum uh he it
was his friend and he said that
eventually he was going to come back to
life and I was like
flies and
guts hanging out I don't think he's just
chilling you kind of sound like a social
worker not really a therapist and he
like I was thinking like on the couch he
just brought like a dead possum to your
office like I used to be a little little
bit more hardcore now I just work with
people in my office it's a lot easier
okay
well you seem like a bit of a pessimist
you know saying that his friend couldn't
come back to life you know maybe
you've never seen pet cemetery
anything's possible I just didn't want
to deal with consequences it's hard
enough dealing with someone who thinks
there's a vampire I don't need a zombie
possum I don't get I didn't get paid
enough for that at the time yeah it was
just like a crossover episode this
Twilight meets [ __ ]
Walking Dead
Chad uh what do you think that uh Alyssa
as your therapist would find out about
you
oh that I really just want to be loved
that's it that's it well luckily you
have a wife so you got that cup that's
why I need love man I got a wife
all these married people on the show
Fiona was the only one up here again I
said I'm keeping my options open I'll
just stop [ __ ] blocking me with this
married thing every time though it's
good that you met up with someone who
also is in a relationship yeah it works
out that way it's better he left too
yeah
he's back
run off together holding hands
oh he's got her a drink oh look at that
now he's trying to one-up me what a nice
guy you don't have to roofie her you're
dating her
in your face chat how do you know I
don't like it
she's a real therapist I am from Florida
a little Florida foreplay
put a little you said that with way too
much confidence like we do that
don't ever go to Blue Martini when
you're down in Naples well good thing uh
I don't know if you know this about us
but we are known to roofie people here
too in Texas it's kind of our thing is
it yeah
um we force feed him a bunch of brisket
and then they fall asleep
I did take a nap today so that makes
sense
my first new coma have you tried the
barbecue down here
that's good huh what was your favorite
place
not out in here but I went to saltlex
really good oh that's good yeah yeah I
like that I'm a big partner all right
I'm still trying to get my time thanks
for uh you're not deleting the
conversation Chad what's your uh
favorite place to go in Florida
for what
for food for food
um Naples depends on do you like seafood
is really going down to no we asked what
your favorite was not what we liked
just like a woman you can't figure out
what she wants to eat you know
it's Florida so probably Chili's or
Applebee's
TGI Friday yeah
yeah the Chili's two for 25 is nice I
like that yeah shadow
if you had to take a if you had to take
Alyssa anywhere what fast food
restaurant do you think would fit her
vibe oh I like Taco Cabana have you been
a Taco Cabana here it's actually pretty
good it's way better than like yeah
let's choose the restaurant we all know
you don't know Taco Cabana
she doesn't okay do not well
someplace okay Red Lobster
Wow Wow real fancy I didn't know they
had a driver
fast food restaurant
it's a good cheddar baby it's good yeah
see I I read that with the with the
beanie there was cheddar bay in the
beanie it's just cold outside it is cold
outside
especially if you're from Florida what
I'm gonna ask me what part of Florida no
yeah he was
yes where are you from oh Naples I know
where that says by the areolas you know
[Laughter]
I
I never mentioned her I don't know about
this yeah that's concerning it could be
the tattoo that could be it yeah
I don't mention it
so uh how long have you guys been
together you and your boyfriend six
months
and oh Chad you definitely got a shot
now dude that's like six months yeah
yeah
exactly
all right maybe not
it's okay my my ex used to bully him in
high school
[Music]
you won though you won or you're winning
right now I'll give you that you're
winning right now this is a Revenge
relationship he's been playing of this
for 23 [ __ ] years this is what this
is he finally got it back oh yeah
how does it feel to uh be a token that
these two men are competing they're like
bulls fighting for you amazing women
yeah
good point
what uh what do you like about uh your
current boyfriend like if you had to
name one thing besides the pool noodle
thing
he's dependable
he's like a Toyota
absolutely look when you got a kid you
need a Toyota oh you have a kid I do is
it twins named Reyna and renera so he's
like the dad you never had he's back in
the running no no I absolutely
how does it feel to know that Wheeling
has a more potent semen than you
he's making twins out here you're making
singles no I got that
oh hell yeah this is the bullies kid
what's that this is the police kid yeah
yeah oh you gotta watch out for that
dude he's gonna be an [ __ ] stepfather
to that kid
this is a bully's kid no no she loves
him oh don't be a dick
yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] drama
the audience members are trying to start
a Jerry Springer chant right now Mori
you are the father
how much did the your bully look like
Chad right now
a little bit not at all six three
wow holy [ __ ]
you want on a date you you dated a
[ __ ] basketball player is your
daughter gonna be tall you see a lot of
stretch in there yeah yeah
yeah was he black no uh
Florida white just just oh the the
germanist of whites oh yeah
germanist
just giving out all kinds of personal
information
and very German
nice the more German the better it's
Kanye says
the name Hans says hell yeah it's what's
up
that's cool so uh yeah so what uh what
what do you think about uh your you know
like does your daughter like what kind
of games do they play together your
trampoline we just got our trampoline
for her birthday I like it you said what
games do you play she went trampoline
Uno Attack
oh
reach the cards back at you it does oh
that's fun yeah
let's not let her win a lot it's a point
of contention yeah he's gonna believe
that kid trust me
it'll make her stronger
she'll end up becoming a professional
poker player
it's like Wheeling
Chad do you have any children I do
they're in their 20s
oh my God you're a dad yeah
he raised them they're done
what kind of how did you discipline them
well you just beat him that's I don't
think I think you're too liberal to beat
anyone no I we're cool we're I mean my
kids are like my roommates because they
pay rent now so like they just hang out
you seem like that guy was like no I'm
like more like your friend not really
your dad you know kinda we smoke weed a
lot together yup yup yeah no my kids are
good we used to they used to run my
stores we used to own businesses that
own retail stores so still put them in
school I put them in the store and child
labor to work yeah cheap labor yeah so
uh do your kids bully you now no I was
just they kick you out of the master
bedroom
Dad we're paying rent now I get the
bathroom
they don't know that part yet don't tell
them dude
so if you had to give uh Alyssa and her
boyfriend any child rearing advice what
would you tell them to do stop being a
dick to that kid I'm telling you now let
her win
she's going to resent you
he's not just not a Nuno yeah
Uno serious it is
Alyssa what uh what do you have to say
to Chad right now is there anything that
you tell like to tell him about his 20
year old children
I have to pay for this kind of therapy
[Music]
I don't know
be more of a dad less of a friend oh I'm
a good dad I really am I'm saying that
my kids won't say that but I'll say it
you're a good dad that goes on dates
with random women on stage
all right Alyssa you give Chad your best
pickup line because he's never gonna
have a woman come up and give him a
pickup line so we gotta like just give
him one I mean let's go
I like it it's the best [ __ ] pickup
line
well give it up for a Chad thank you
everybody
they're gonna get let's going
we got Emma a female coming up
here yeah give it a prima guys don't be
dicks
making our way on up
we're gonna interview her and then we're
gonna set her up on a date with one of
our many eligible bachelors
or dime a dozen hello Emma welcome
Hi how are you tonight I'm good how are
you great what uh what uh what what
brings you out to this dating show
um my best friend is in town Fiona
oh nice
green Fiona Gumby yeah what's up um so
we decided to come out I've been here
once before so I was like I know this is
going on let's go nice
and uh she's just visiting from uh
another city in Texas yeah from Waco
nice
uh that's cool Waco's not too far
um what do you think do you think she's
like a religious nut she's got a
compound over there
should they all dressed like her in a
green track suits that's that's the new
uniform for the cult out there it's all
green they do if you're not wearing
green you're not allowed why didn't you
bring this up earlier
Waco nice uh so that's cool what uh what
do you like about Austin have you ever
maybe convinced uh Fiona to maybe move
to a real City
I've been working on it but
um yeah Austin's cool I don't know
I don't know yeah it's a cool City
have you ever been on a lot of dates
with uh Tech Bros here
not really actually
most of my time in Austin I was in a
relationship so I didn't go on too too
many dates until recently but
nice how uh what kind of person was this
person you were in a relationship with
like a tattoo artist
it's the only two types of people that
are in Austin Tech Bros and tattoo
artists no he ran um a medical clinic
um
that's funny to people from Florida
they're like you got medicine here yeah
cause they're they all know what he
really means is he just he just shoots
people up with ketamine charges in 50
bucks it's not too far off
yeah
they do not respect the medicine
medicinal profession in Florida they uh
they're used to just getting
opioids from them
um but so he was uh some Works in
medicine he's
he's like a nurse or something
uh no he just managed the clinics oh
he's like a like a
manager yeah
well that's fun okay well that's a lot
to live up to this next guy coming up
you better have a job at least yeah
don't be poor either we're tired of that
no pores
she's a real woman she needs a real man
let's see if Joss School jerk a sicko
is the man for the job what's his name
Josh
how is that why did how did you
put a seat you are a doctor because your
handwriting is terrible yeah the sea is
supposed to be in Josh I don't know why
but C is supposed to be a Josh all right
both of you repeat your names Josh Emma
cool Hi how are you
I made sure to wear green okay you're
acceptable
did we talk about what you did for work
no we did not I wasn't paying attention
for half of what you were saying so
we're gonna go in blood here what do you
do that's okay
um I work at a medical clinic
yeah the pill Mill we kind of talked
about it did we
don't know yeah kind of do you like it I
do I actually put my two weeks in um so
you don't like it that much
no I really like it and they're
wonderful
um but I'm a senior at UT and I have the
hardest muscle in my life coming up so
I'm like I'm gonna focus on that what is
it with SMART Girls they'd rather like
study than actually work
I mean gotta you know
gotta pay attention in school gotta get
the A's what do you do for fun
they cut off your mic
this apparently this is what you this is
the only thing you do
um this and I do pull I pull dance okay
so is that your backup it is okay you
know in case being a doctor can you get
her into it
I can I tried to go to class today but
they canceled it
thank you Nick everybody get up for Nick
one more time
he's got a [ __ ] great name
are you gonna ask me any questions
a back and forth would be
um I'm an idiot and ride motorcycles
like one
I'm a
scary story
my favorite scary story not a crash um
it's when I got arrested
um I was riding basically yeah yeah only
time I've been to jail
listen [ __ ] happens okay
I beat her in the face with a pool
noodle you don't think I'd go to jail
end time good up for this Florida love
story
so I was correct he's spontaneous and he
assaulted his girlfriend
I love it you're so demanding you're
like are you gonna ask me questions
it's like I'm tired of this sexism in
the the dating world
you're uh giving her advice you're like
smart girls always study they never work
for someone who looks like you failed
out of high school that's
really lofty advice I actually graduated
early
wow because they wanted to get rid of
you
so uh how did you uh graduate early did
you
um so the county we lived in did a
program where you could leave and just
take the test then we don't do geds so
they were like here's your high school
diploma is that where you got that
misspelled [ __ ] tattoo on your farm
that's Greek no I know it's a joke
I'm a professional
is that come and take it it is nice
welcome to Texas thank you very much
yeah
that's cool so you're really into uh
white supremacy or
I'm too polish for that oh you're a
Russian
Eastern European slav a little bit uh
Polish people actually hate Russians I
think
possibly
how's the uh how's old Poland doing you
guys hanging in there no idea you're the
Tannis Polish person I've ever seen I
live in Florida and ride motorcycles oh
hell yes a lot as a scooter rider I
don't know that uh a [ __ ] uh pole
plus Florida equals Mexican
[Music]
she's right can you do a Hispanic accent
no
like a Mexican your homes I'm I'm a
Polish kid from the East side of Detroit
I'm as white as they get oh you're from
Detroit yeah nice Emma what do you think
about this poll
would you like to dance on it
uh it took a while
hahaha
the best part is I wouldn't get in
trouble
this is a very unstable pole I don't
think he has a job
do you like guys that ride motorcycles
yeah what do you think of this uh
stepsons of Anarchy over here
very safe you work in the medical field
you don't want to be a patient
if this guy came in all busted up what
would you say to him
whoa not a good bedside manner
she's more into like the house method of
healing patients
sounds a little hitlery over there
you're dumb enough to be born Jewish
[Laughter]
whoa whoa a twist
a Jew and a pole walk into a bar
yeah don't procreate Hitler will come
back from the dead and try and kill your
children
Kanye so what do you like about being
Jewish
you're not Jew full
y okay that's where they come from
are you trying to say you're not wealthy
no she's saying she's extra wealthy I'm
European Jew you scumbag yeah not like
one of those Middle Eastern Jews
you just perfected it
you're just claiming it extra hard now
that it's very popular to be Jewish
right now you're like yeah I'm Jewish
yeah so popular
yeah the Jews you know they do control
the media what do you think about uh
Kanye
I'm so cool
that's my dad's Department he controls
the media you know
you know who my father is
you don't you don't get high on your own
Supply
he's all right
he's just a free thinker
Paul
[Laughter]
yeah you have anything to say to the
Jewish person not as a Jewish person
what do you have to say in general
nothing really this was fun maybe a
little Shalom rude he said how do you do
what do you what do you have to say to
the Jew he goes nothing
I just have a message
give it up for the Chinese guy giving a
drink to Emma
a partnership
partnership As Old As Time a Jew and a
Chinese person my lady's slacking I
don't get a drink it reminds me of
Christmas already uh
Jew getting
Chinese takeout yeah
I set it up
[Laughter]
so how do you know this [ __ ]
he brings her take out
does your dry cleaning
oh an improv class
you do Improv
yeah Jews are known for their improv
Chinese people not so much they're known
for taking it out
for fake Gucci products and Rolexes and
iPhones thank you appreciate you does he
just do what you did but package it
slightly differently like with an i
instead of an e
EMA my name is Emma
well that's cool uh so how long have you
been in Detroit or where how long did
you spend in Detroit uh I split about 50
50. so oh 15 years in Michigan 15 years
in Florida okay so is your first 15
years you spent Detroit nice
that's a good choice
I think so oh really yeah what did you
learn in Detroit that you could teach us
white people
you know Freeway Ricky Ross Rick Ross is
he from Detroit no it just sounds like
he should be
um no I just it's just where I grew up
nothing everybody gives it a bad rap He
didn't he was just born into it
he chose Florida over Michigan I didn't
even choose Florida
doesn't seem like it
you fit Florida you look like a mascot
for Florida
part of a Florida Man story so like it
checks out of course you are you're from
Florida every Florida man has been in
the newspaper for some dumb ass [ __ ]
that they did which one did you do did
you kill the alligator or throw it
through the drive-through window at
McDonald's it's it's even better um I
was a loss prevention officer for about
a decade and uh long story short I was
bit by a guy named dick oranges
that's a true story if you Google dick
oranges there's like 15 different
articles about it that's the last time
I'm getting minute made
naturally
if you Google it it'll come up
this is
not dick oranges this is just a writing
exercise for the audience now
well that's cool you uh did the Florida
thing uh Emma would you ever go to
Florida or would you hang out with dick
oranges
hell yeah
obviously
a lot of Jews there
where in Florida does your family live
in
yep then get it then get it for free
down there you know
nice a real Jew
um Paul where do you think that you
would take uh Emma on a date
well she she doesn't like motorcycles so
I mean it would be boring just going in
my truck so it's not even fun
this it's just never gonna work hey she
just [ __ ] hates you bro it's cool
sometimes it goes like that we've all
been on first day at where you're like
you know what no I don't know we're
never doing anything my girl can be as
cool as mine so you hate trucks you hate
your motorcycles you're Jewish so I know
you hate trains
[Laughter]
how do you get around
that's kind of a truck yeah
it's it's the impracticality of the gas
mileage of a truck without the utility
of it it's just a bad decision
you like SUVs what do you drive an SUV
and uh how does it make you feel
very safe
yeah that's good good to know
that you'll be running over protesters
instead of the other way around
what about time Jews took power
so uh
uh
uh Josh
what uh what what do you like about kill
Tony that brought you out here
uh it's to fix a wrong done by her
ex-husband
what happened with her bully or your
bully her ex-husband they uh she wanted
to kill Tony for her birthday um back
when it was at the comedy store and he
took her to Utah or Montana or some [ __ ]
like that so when I got a wrong
opportunity for the tickets to come in I
was like yo we're going for your
birthday
and then you were like let's wait two
years and then make you pay for it
wait but did he go like babe we're gonna
go to kill Tony and then took you to
Utah like he booked the wrong City I I
picked the wrong date
oh okay I was gonna say that would have
been hilarious that is some Florida [ __ ]
right there we're going to kill Tony
welcome to Utah
as uh there's a lot of stores there not
a lot of Comedy
um that's cool so you're actually being
a better boyfriend you're doing
everything that he couldn't I think I'm
doing pretty good nice what's like
something that you do romantically for
her
oh do the dishes
do the dishes so romantic like you have
no idea she she when we weren't living
together like her sink was oh every day
I got there was full like three days
worth I'm like what is going on so I do
the dishes that's what happens when
you're like Florida and you don't have
access to Mexicans Ian did destroy her
house so like that's
every Texas sink is clean as a [ __ ]
whistle
Emma give uh Josh some dating advice to
keep his girlfriend happy
if you have one piece of advice to give
him
hit you in the face of the Blue Angel
it worked what what would you like to be
hit in the face with
not the bill
she's Jewish
[Laughter]
not even with a shiny new hundred dollar
bill
figures
so uh where did you grow up you grew up
mostly in Texas or
yeah okay what's like some East Coast
gangster [ __ ] you can teach this Detroit
hoodlum
yeah I want to hear what you think
gangster [ __ ] is just start wrapping
Iggy Azalea
please do
do it
pound that drink and start rapping
every white girl has it in her to start
rapping
okay
maybe you could do like uh one of those
dances that Jewish people do what is
that
so how did you get into we have one
right here
do it do it this is a florida-sized pool
how did you get into pole dancing
you're getting ready for the big leagues
the Yellow Rose you know
yellow rose red rose check them out
you're like I'm not getting enough
creepy comments from dudes
let me go try to get some more
are there any dudes that do this
yeah yeah check it checks out
what
dragged your brother there
I'm sure he was loving he's just sitting
in the corner beating off like look at
all these girls on the poles like I
don't even have to throw dollar bills
what are you doing Steph sis
well
I'm trying to
train you're a horrible sister let him
get [ __ ]
bring him up here next time we'll get
them laid let's do it
what a liberal groomer are you sure
you're not a school school teacher
so uh Paul are you vaccinated nope
do they have vaccines in Florida or is
it just it's meth yeah basically
stronger the myth of the better the
disease fighting capabilities that's
right basically yeah no I mean it was
Florida just didn't care if you want to
do it you want to do it if you don't you
don't just be respectful and that's kind
of how we did it nobody in Florida is
respectful we've all read the papers
like they do what they want to do but
they're like I don't respect nobody
where I live in Florida is actually from
Florida except her and like four other
people so so you live in the Austin of
Florida yeah okay yeah I mean oh yeah
who's your Joe Rogan [ __ ] Joe exotic
I mean it yeah
there's no one that would be better for
Florida than him so
what uh what's the craziest thing that
you've seen have you ever been to one of
those uh tiger sanctuaries
no um but the area of Florida that I
live in is like it is really the the
Texas of Florida we have like rhinos and
tigers that live all around us in like a
big wolf sanctuary yeah fat people yeah
yeah how do you think they get the
models for those t-shirts those awesome
wolf t-shirts anyways uh
Emma what do you uh what are you looking
for in a date in Austin
you're afraid of the dark we get it
yeah
so you're more like a bookworm you're
like a librarian
nice describe your perfect man
okay
basic anyway
describe your perfect woman
she's sitting right there good answer
good answer that was a test it was a
test even with the beanie
oh [ __ ] damn do you get a makeover
hell yeah dude
good job man do you watch movies on that
drive-in theater projection of a
forehead
oh
it's all Doctor Who
how does that feel to have a smart woman
it pays a lot
just gotta commenter and it lets me have
three motorcycles and not worry about it
so
awesome dude you're living the life
you're just chilling getting a therapist
you're just a sugar baby that's all you
really are I do have a job yeah part
time at Little Caesars
look at this overachiever over here I
gotta keep the Detroit game alive
what do you do I'm an estimator so like
right now I'm working a lot with like
all the hurricane Ian damage so we're
just putting people's houses back
together I estimate that you'll be
getting a lot of [ __ ] tonight
it's every night
how do you keep it fresh how do you uh
make sure that it happens every night
hit her in the face with [ __ ]
a few you guys just came in it's this
whole thing
we're not actually advocating for we
don't want the abuse to happen but it
happens you know
if it's gonna he's into CNC you know
she's loving that reference yeah the
Florida thing no it's consensual
non-consensual I just learned it with my
like my last ex-girlfriend it's weird
yeah you guys are more power too you
know what I'm saying
you guys are weird
[Laughter]
Emma what's the uh what's the what
happened to that relationship that you
were in Austin with for a while
it was pretty good
no you know made your complaints up
uh did he uh you guys broke up did he
write too many bird Scooters or take
your paddle boarding too many times
so you dumped him
how did he take it
he made him cry
[ __ ]
convert we asked the questions here okay
ah
so yeah but did he ask to convert
oh so he's a real Jew too okay
two Jews
fighting over a penny
that's how copper wire was invented
so uh are you looking for Jewish guys or
was that just a coincidence
it was a coincidence we met on Jay date
you know
actually
hey us too sweet
so you met your girlfriend on hinge yep
what did you say to her
I don't even remember you just sent her
a gift of getting a girl getting hit in
the face with a noodle probably probably
hot that's how foreplay happens in
Florida
uh but yeah you guys met online
um do you guys ever like you know
reminisce about online dating and like
you're texting her and you're like we
did like three days ago
what happened
um so she friendzoned me and digging out
of that again we went back into that and
like talking about something I don't
even remember I was high sitting on the
couch that was the end of the night yeah
oh you got Stoned on the first date
you're like yeah I'm gonna go on this
date and be like uh the whole time and
of course I'm gonna get laid
oh yeah you were doomed from the start
she was like you're getting friend zoned
immediately we argue if that counts as
our actual first aid now yeah it does
and it's a shitty one it does it does
it's a shitty one thank you do you have
a role play like oh let's just pretend
I'm friend zoned again I'm just gonna
jerk off in the corner it's on the list
now
oh yeah they're gonna do it that's how
we keep
Emma have you ever friend zoned anybody
have you ever let a friend out of the
friend zone
wow Alyssa
[Music]
she's making it look like a [ __ ]
I'm just kidding it worked out for you
look he
you took him to Texas and paid for
everything it's totally working out
thank you for Emma what uh what What's
the like weirdest guy that's in the
friend zone right now
you want to give him a shout out on the
internet
oh you haven't told him yet you're just
like you've determined it but you're
like I just want attention from time to
time so I don't want to turn off my
attention buttons you know
yeah why do you think we do this show
yeah
that's cool friend zoning is a great
power I hope you use it responsibly
um
so what uh what what how many dates have
you been on since your relationship
what was the best out of the three
um
um that's why it was the best one you're
like I never have to see him again so it
wasn't enough
y'all went on a date and then he was
like no I'm going back to Washington how
bad were you on the date Jesus
he Washington zoned you
you know those washingtonians always
dancing around up there like a
bunch of fairies
uh that's cool so you went on a dancing
date
um if you had to friend zone any one of
us on stage right now who would you
friend zone first and why
motorcycle I knew that was coming you
got back it was the answer to both
questions with one word
you got bad news right written all over
your forearms but I've got good credit
so that works oh wow yeah because she
pays for everything I bought our house
it's a Florida house it can't be that
expensive
it's called a trailer park
yeah when I when I bought a new
refrigerator I donated that house to
Florida as well
well give it up for Emma and Josh Josh
thank you guys
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out
thank you Josh thank you thank you have
a good night
a lot of people in relationships tonight
yeah a bunch of bunch of cheaters yeah
a bunch of disloyal [ __ ] dirty dirty
cheaters well that was the show what did
you think about the contestants tonight
you know there are some good ones
there's some nice uh outfit attire some
good first aid outfits you know we had
Gumby up here we had stepsons of Anarchy
we had we had some good jokes good
banter the audience was good they played
it they played along but they didn't get
too mouthy because they didn't want to
get smacked by a wet noodle
the wet noodle of Comedy
um Nick's apocalia is on Instagram he
has drinking coffee with Nick on
Instagram and check it out Nick fitzwell
on all social medias whoa drinking
coffee with Nick he feds well Nick
fitzwell any hole anyway dude holes yeah
sometimes but some oh uh well I know
what I'm gonna be doing after the show
tonight it's getting fit fitting well
and getting fit well
uh my name is Hans Camp thank you guys
so much
so much thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]